hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tilting against windmills
Clarity and spectral panel design
without losing the battle for biological
resolution
I am Matt Ashton of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more visit thermalfisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to not welcome our speaker said
and Thomas staff scientist Thermo Fisher
Scientific second you may not begin your
presentation
all right thanks so much
um so the title of the talk is again
tilting against windmills Clarity and
spectral panel design without losing the
battle for biological resolution
and uh just what I'm referring to this
idea of tilting against windmills comes
from Don Quixote and the idea that
instead of fighting a monster as he
thought he was fighting a windmill and
since a windmill would continue to turn
no matter what it was always going to be
a losing battle
um in terms of that and so it's a really
good analogy just to start thinking
about spectral panel design so the
problem with building to higher
parameters is both the limit of the
detectors available for the unmixing as
well as the increasing spread and so um
you know you really want to look at what
dies you're using uh in terms of
utilizing this underutilized space so
when you look at a spectral panel
there's a lot of spots that are really
not used
um and so
um we also are trying to use lessons
learned from previous 45 color
panel design to really drive that new
panel design and the goal is really to
understand how pushing towards a
theoretical maximum parameters affects
panel design and biological resolution
and one of my goals is to make this
clear so that you instead of fighting
against the way something works you're
working with that and using that to help
solve the problem as you build towards
higher parameters in your panel
and so you know the idea here is that
when you think about Hardware Innovation
it's really driving dye development so
back when the there was really just a
Four Color fax caliber there really was
very little pressure to have more dyes
uh as you start to have more um
sophisticated cytometers going to 12 18
colors and then pushing into spectral
you really
um you know move to this pressure point
where the high parameters puts pressure
on detecting similar fluorescent labels
and accommodating non-ideal dye
performance and so you know as you can
see you know there's just this continued
increase in terms of what the diet how
the dyes need to perform
and so when we think about you know
conventional cytometry versus spectral
cytometry I think this is one place for
us to really understand what's going on
um and so I have here a Dye APC and you
can see that you know you have your
excitation curve in this dotted line and
then you have your emission curve and so
EPC is predominantly excited off of the
red laser you can see here from the
excitation curve that it would also be
excited predictably excited off with the
yellow green laser but not so much off
of the rest of the lasers however when
you look at um you know a spectral
signature what you can see is it tells
us a little bit different set of
information
so of course you do see the fluorescence
coming off of the red laser and that is
the primary emission spot and you do see
this emission coming from the excitation
off the yellow green laser but one of
the things that you don't necessarily
capture is the fact that there is this
emission also coming off of the Violet
and the UV and so sometimes what
spectral cytometry does is really show
us what is happening even on a
conventional instrument and so you know
if you've used a number of dies and
start to notice hey this is you know
affecting some of the other detectors
spectral cytometry is just showing us
hey this is predicted actually based on
this dye and so we can really see what's
happening
um you know in your overall panel and
this is happening whether you're using a
conventional or a spectral instrument
and so this is just showing you again
what we would think of as the off-target
emission spots in terms of that
cross-sex citation
and so you know when you look in
spectral cytometry you have a Dye
signature and it's really the results of
non-ideal dye Performance used to great
effect for phenotyping and so you can
see here up top you have APC and at the
bottom you have Alexa floor 647 and
although that the on this uh Aurora you
can see that APC is primarily detected
in R1 and Alexa floor 647 is primarily
detected in R2 the real difference when
you look at a signature is not so much
what's happening in the primary Channel
but some of the differences that are
happening perhaps in the violet or the
UV because it's this entire signature
that's being looked at and so you know
understanding that really
um helps you both in your panel design
and increase the theoretical limit of
the colors in the panel
and so one of the things we tried to
think about on the die side was how does
underlying conventional dye performance
affect your panel design and
conventional dies can only perform in
two ways and both can lead to spread or
loss of data resolution and so in this
slide you can see here we have something
like brilliant Violet 510 which is great
in that it's not cross-excited but this
broad emission that takes up a large
number of channels in the Violet
Spectrum still can be somewhat
problematic as you start to detect more
and more dyes and then there's other
dyes like PE and PE Dazzle and Percy P
that are cross-excited by both the blue
and yellow green laser and again those
are taking up spots so if you had
something that was excited off of only
one of the lasers it's taking up less
space in your panel
additionally when you think about
spillover and data resolution here's an
example from the University of Chicago
blog and you can see here that it's
showing the plots for APC size 7 and PE
size 7 and you can see that in terms of
their emission although they're excited
primarily by different lasers that their
mission is also is is in a similar spot
and so just as an example here this is
showing you if you had a single color
control with APC size 7 and use this
uncompensated and then the idea of if
you applied compensation
and in an ideal setting you would
imagine that this would line up
perfectly uh you would have no you know
detection in PE size 7 from this single
color control
in reality what you see is this it looks
like either a trumpet or a goldfish tail
this spillover spreading error and so
what this means is that you're losing
resolution of your data so if you had
you know something that was incredibly
bright you you know would easily be able
to separate it but if you had something
dimmer it would be harder to determine
what is noise and what is your signal
and so you know in this context we would
refer to EPC size 7 as the perpetrator
and PE size 7 as the victim so basically
you're losing that resolution in your PE
size 7 Channel because of this
so we stepped back and said you know uh
could you know we really design a better
performing die and what would that look
like so there's an imaginary die here
perfect blue and you can see that that's
showing up in one of the 64 detectors
off of the Aurora and then we have a tad
less than perfect blue and so perfect
blue would be great to have but it does
break some of the laws of physics and
that you would have you know have to
have some decline in terms of this it's
you know not acting just in that one
detector and so the goal would really be
to generate something a tad less than
perfect blue so so having you know a
really strong signal no cross-sec
citation and a very rapid decline in
terms of the other channels
that's what we tried to do here you can
see um with the uh in vitrogen phyton
technology we're taking single stranded
DNA and then it is then folded into this
cruciform structure and what that allows
for is for us to position dies very
specifically on this structure and so
you can act we can actually engineer the
excitation in the mission so this is
using fret technology so using
positioning a donor an acceptor diet
specific positions to engineer this
fluorescence by Design
and then we can attach that to the
antibody we haven't done as much with
this but this does also enable us to
tune brightness if we wanted to instead
of putting it on two of the arms put it
on more so in this example it's just
showing you the idea of having a four
cluster version
so you know if you think about what
you'd want in terms of die requirements
you'd really want something to be bright
and clean really to limit laser
crosstalk citation and minimize spread
you'd want it to be consistent and
stable and ideally have controllable
brightness to match based on antigen
density in the panel that you're using
so we tried to take a few different
targeted approach approaches to
designing new fluorescent labels and so
I'm going to be talking about this but
we started with the idea of separating
out you know one of the primary issues
with blue and yellow green excitation as
compared to existing PE and PE tandems
and then I'll talk about another a
number of other things that we've
approached in terms of thinking about
die design
so in terms of thinking about your panel
the idea is that piggy Dazzle you can
see this is an excitation curve rather
than an emission curve
um and so what that's showing you is
that something like PE Dazzle is excited
primarily
um it's it's excited by the blue laser
and the yellow green laser whereas
something like Nova floor blue 610 is
excited primarily by the blue laser and
not so much by the yellow laser and the
same for Nova floor yellow 610 is
excited primarily by the yellow laser
and not so much by the blue laser and so
what this does is really allow you to
get this two-for-one situation where you
can actually use two Nova floors in
place of just one you know previous PE
Tandem and of course this depends on
having the filters so a number of folks
that have built cytometers before this
have built around this problem and
that's why you tend to see less
detectors off the blue blue laser but
that's not necessarily required
and so the next thing we try to attack
was this problem of building more red
shifted dyes and so when you think about
the goal is really to you know get
something that is a long Stoke shift
from a defined primary laser so here you
can see you have your typical donor die
you have your acceptor die and you have
high spectral overlap and so it's very
easy to transfer that energy from the
donor dog to the acceptor but when you
think about doing this you know further
down across the Spectrum you can see
that then the donor can be excited but
it would just tend to emit where it is
because it's too far away from the
acceptor and so thinking about you know
how to solve this problem
and I'm just putting this here
um from you know a small subset showing
off the yellow yellow green and red off
of the Aurora and you can see that there
are these large gaps so between yg5 and
9 uh they're not so many dies in between
R4 and R8 so there's these open spots
and this really does relate to building
more red shifted dyes in that way
so if you think about this challenge
um in this case the idea you know in
terms of American football that you know
if you're throwing a short distance
um it's you know not so hard to make
that pass but if you're throwing a
really long distance you require more
energy to make that pass you you know
really need to be very specific in terms
of reaching you know in this analogy
someone that's going to catch that ball
they're going to have to have a lot more
skill and so it's a similar idea in
terms of this challenge so you have to
go a long distance across the challenge
and cross-sec citation can be an issue
when you think about this in terms of
the dies the acceptor is larger and more
unstable enough susceptible to oxidation
so this is definitely something that
we're continuing to build towards and we
are in process of building more
redshifted dyes that will be released to
Market I think
um as of this past month we've released
Nova floor blue 690 and again we'll be
releasing more of these red shifted dies
in the future off of these laser lines
so when you think about
um you know the challenge in terms of
um Switching gears you know building out
ultraviolet and more Violet dyes which
we had not released yet as Nova floors
UV and violet excited dyes are harder to
separate from the background due to the
autofluorescence of specific cellular
components
and so you can see here this is again
coming from uh Aurora the Aurora and
this is just showing unstained cells
unsane ppmcs and you can see that there
are contributors in terms of
autofluorescence
um off of the UV and violet background
and these can include amino acids
structural proteins energy Pathways so
you're picking that up in these cells so
that means that you have to build your
brightness higher to get the separation
because you already have some more
background noise there
and also the extinction coefficients are
generally lower for smaller UV excited
um
levels that lead to lower energy
emission on a per molecule basis so just
calling this out so the UV dyes that
have been released thus far in terms of
the brilliant UVS those are polymers
versus single floors and so that's one
way to build you know around this
problem in terms of the extinction
coefficients of having to put more dyes
on them per molecule basis
um and there's also the issue of the use
of lower powered lasers for these UV
excited dyes especially on uh the Aurora
and so this is an example which was
pretty interesting I think so if you
look at uh qdot 800
um so this
uh bot in terms of its excitation would
tend to be excited more by the UV laser
than the Violet laser however the Aurora
has a 20 milliwatt laser for the UV and
100 milliwatt laser for the Violet so
five times as much so instead of showing
up the primary channel in the UV the
primary Channel shows up in the Violet
and that's really related to the lasers
and how this is detected
however when you look at the um in
nutrition flow cytometry panel Builder
this is showing you for the seven laser
Bigfoot sorter you can see that you know
basically the qdot 800 would be
predicted to have its primary excitation
coming off the UV laser and less off the
Violet because these lasers are both 100
milliwatts so when you're using that
equivalent see that's what you have
and so uh just you know taking you into
a little more detail here this is um you
know showing you the instrument
configuration for the Aurora and the
different laser wattages and you know
what when you think about
um the Aurora versus the Bigfoot you can
see that
um you have apds on the Aurora versus
pmts on the Bigfoot uh the
um Aurora uses the apds and so it will
tend to detect better in the red and
worse off of the UV and the Violet just
because of the physics of how that works
and the converse situation in terms of
the Bigfoot so you would tend to detect
better in the UV and not as much into
the red and you can also see that there
are different wattages of these lasers
which always affects the signature of a
die so these are the things that we're
sort of looking at as we're building new
new dies
um when you think about them taking all
of this information and Switching gears
in terms of panel design
there are a lot of things that you're
dealing with and you don't necessarily
these problems don't go away just
because you're switching from
conventional to spectral cytometry and
some of those are thinking about
spectral overlap
antigen density so you know do you have
something that's bright enough to match
for a lower expressed antigen or
something that's a little dimmer for
something that's
um you know perhaps you know more highly
expressed
um and then you know thinking about the
spillover spreading which I discussed
before and again matching that staining
index to the antigen density
and so this is showing you uh the Nova
floor dies that we've released thus far
we've also released Nova floor blue 690
um so
um but we really haven't released
anything into the UV and the Violet and
so you know refer to that as Purple Rain
so I'd say stay tuned but in the
meantime uh Therma Fisher has actually
released uh both antibodies conjugated
off of the buv and the BV in terms of
the dice the brilliant ultraviolet and
Brilliant Violet dies so that's
something that you can use in uh in the
meantime to really build out your panel
more fully
and so we also are continuing to expand
the Nova floor antibody conjugates so um
this is with the original 19 dies we
have all of these clones in all of these
dies
um and this is actually out of date I
think we've reached greater than 100
clones at this point in terms of Nova
floor conjugated antibodies so you know
if you haven't seen it there before keep
checking the catalog because the team's
been working pretty hard on that release
and we're trying to make sure that we're
matching up places where the ant body is
bright enough to give the separation
that you need for that specific antibody
so we look at all of those issues
so
um now stepping back and really thinking
specifically about spectral panel design
the goal is to build around cross-sec
citation and spectral spread by
selecting specially clean dies and
utilizing the spectral distribution in
the panel
and so what you can see here this is
just showing you the spectral
Distribution on your Aurora and at left
you have the different wavelengths
approximately that would be there you
have the different channels and then the
different floors that would be primarily
detected in those channels
and so
um you know this is one way to really
look at what's what's happening
um and so I think one of the things to
draw your attention to is something like
buv 661 so you can see here that it
might not necessarily be obvious that
you would actually have some cross
expectation off of the red laser but you
can really see that when you have laid
out the dies this way so I I find this
layout actually pretty helpful when I'm
building sorry when I'm building to
um you know a larger panel here
um and so you can see you know that's
one way to look at that so if you had
something that might be highly expressed
and cause an issue in terms of your
panel you might put something on say
buv395 or 805 or somewhere else so that
you weren't dealing with this cross-sex
citation issues
um in addition
um as you're building a panel thinking
about you know what cells you're putting
next to each uh what antigens you're
putting next to each other so you know
you might put you could put something
like CD4 and cd8 but you might you know
avoid something that would be
co-expressed on both those cells because
it makes it harder to resolve and so
that brings me to you know another
question that you should really think
about as you're building out your
spectral panel so consider if your panel
is meant to address broad or deep immuno
phenotyping
and so I just want to define those terms
quickly in a broad panel you really want
to position co-expressed markers to
avoid spectral spread or cross-sec
citation and so an example of this might
be looking at multiple lineages in a
panel so T Cell B cell monocyte
macrophage
um you know those are going to be
expressed on different cell types and so
you can actually get around sometimes
bad die performance by positioning these
on different cells so they won't be
co-expressed
um in the Deep panel fewer colors can be
used and you're often dealing with
co-expression so this is showing you
know for instance the idea of a T Cell
only panel so you might be looking at
activated CD4 T cells and then T-Rex and
those are going to share a number of
markers and then have others where
they're not and so you can never build
to as many colors with a deep panel
because you really have to deal much
more with dye performance than
positioning the dies around you know the
different cell populations
in addition panel design is still
related to dye antibody clone breadth as
well as availability and so what do I
mean by that so here you know if you
think about that
um you know if there's say your favorite
antibody is only available in three
colors and you've already used up those
colors in your panel you you know will
have to think about a new way even if
you've built a better panel and then of
course you know we've all been dealing
in the pandemic with availability issues
so you may have built the best panel in
the world but if you have to wait on
that antibody sometimes you have to
switch gears and so it's very important
to think about you know how you plan for
that in your experiment
um so
um I set a goal to build a broad immune
panel with spots for selection of
fluorophores with the most available
antigens so thinking about Fitzy or
Alexa floor 488 PE and APC or Alexa
floor 647 and the idea is that you know
as we go along with Immunology someone
is always discovering the next important
molecule that's going to be important
for your work and so leaving a space
already built into the panel so that you
can actually drop in what you need is
actually pretty important to be thinking
ahead so that you're ready for that and
so you know here you can see this is a
panel that I've built out and I put
those available spots into the panel and
had to then think about you know how the
dies perform
um you know even if they have something
in there as a whole placeholder
and so you can see here for instance uh
again to come back to that issue in
terms of cross-sex citation what I did
so that I could use you know this this
full part is position you know igd which
would be on the B cells uh CD
um
cd1c
um and uh CD sorry this small uh sorry
CD
um three on T cells so really trying to
position the cells so that they're not
co-expressing uh on these particular
floors
um and so the other thing that
um I wanted to look at also was the same
thing so looking at positioning
um you know CD4 and cd8
um so even even though those are both on
T cells positioning them you know they
can you can be positioned here because
they are still on separate T Cell
populations and then looking at other
markers like monocyte marker
and sort of separating those out so
making sure that I'm trying to look at
different cell types so that you know
you're dealing less with the issues of
spread into these channels
um and then again as I mentioned already
leaving these spots available to
continue to build
uh the next thing you really have to
deal with is making sure that your
antibodies are titrated for the specific
Channel and brightness those sufficient
to resolved populations of interest and
this is important no matter what
cytometer you're using but it can also
be an issue that maybe an antibody dye
pairing is sub-optimal and so in this
case my initial positioning I was put
putting CD 127 on buv-496 and so you
know when I tested that particular
conjugate it really didn't have enough
expression even as I titrated up and
gated on the lymphocyte population as
compared with the controls here in
buv737 or super bright 436 so either
using you know the same clone or a
different clone still really didn't
identify that population so this was
something that you know after building
out the panel dealing with any you know
issues of Supply then had to re-look at
that and so just as an example here this
change even in a CD 127 means that you
know I can switch that over from here
um to moving that in place of the super
bright 702 and then you know because I
had built this rather tightly having to
move cd11c to buv 661 and then moving
igd to fit C in this placeholders space
and so these are the kinds of issues
that you typically you know need to deal
with so you may have tested your panel
on paper but once you test it you know
and even do the titration before testing
out the panel this is an issue
and so again here there's a place where
really needed the brightness for ccr4 so
we needed to switch that clone and
um then also
um switch out you know have something in
here in terms of pd1 and cd86 just to
have something to test into
um so you know now that I've talked
about sort of Designing this on paper
titrating your antibodies then really
also thinking about selecting dye
combinations to minimize the similarity
index and so that's the pairwise measure
of the spectral uniqueness and the
complexity score which is a measure of
the difficulty of the panel to unmix and
really avoid spectral punching so what
do I mean by this
so this is showing you
um the Therma Fisher panel builder in
this case it's taking you know a
previously used Aurora panel and so what
you can see here is that you've got you
know one die and so when you get into
the darker blue that's showing you that
these two dies are very similar to each
other and thus will not be a good
combination so you can still sometimes
use them it just means that that would
be less recommended but as you build
more and more colors it's always going
to become a bit more of an issue
um but interestingly when you put you
know say three dies that are played in a
similar place there's actually a worse
unmixing than you see with any of the
individual dyes and so this is what I
mean by Spectral bunching so you
actually see that you know while you can
use this it leads to worse issues that
are captured and interestingly
um you know when you're building out the
panel you can look in the panel builder
at the complexity score and one of the
things I noticed as I was building this
was that the complexity score didn't
necessarily go up when I added these in
a very small panel and uh what you know
when I talk to a mathematician about
this what they said is that early number
was already telling you you had made the
worst decision possible and so by adding
these two additional dies that were you
know in the third die that was in this
area basically it's already saying I've
made the worst possible decision but the
complexity score isn't necessarily
reflecting that and so it's just worth
being aware of that the complexity score
doesn't necessarily capture all of that
nor does the similarity index so just
being aware as you're looking at your
panel about you know that issue
and this also happens for the
combination of db515 Fitzy and Nova
floor blue 530.
so what you can see here again going
back to this panel is the idea that
um if you step backwards you can see
places where I could have included more
of these dies and so what I've done is
draw a box showing you that while I
could could have used all three of these
dies together in general that's not
going to be your best panel design and
the truth is you can build some more
colors but if you don't have the
biological resolution it really is a
problem and so in these two cases as I
showed you before I would tend to avoid
using one of those so you could use two
of the three to get better resolution so
that's just worth noting here
um and you know last as you start to
build and test your panel you really
want to assess Channel resolution
through the spectral spread Matrix to
avoid
um remove spread and identify dies that
act as perpetrators and victims so how
do you view that
um so if you actually in uh flojo and I
believe it's also available in FCS
Express you can generate the spectral
spread Matrix and so what this does is
sort of give you a relative indication
of the spread
and so when you add this up so if
there's you know a column of dies here
you can see when you add this up the row
sum should be able to identify
fluorophores that cause a lot of
spillover
um and this would be then the
perpetrators
if you look at the column sum you can
identify fluorophores that have a lot of
spillover and that's important to really
understand you know where he's going to
start seeing the problems in your panel
so those are the places where you might
not have enough resolution to be able to
you know resolve your populations and so
you might need to think of what's
contributing to that and it could be
multiple floors there so just to be
aware of that and to show you an example
of that data this was you know some
learning from the initial 45 plus color
panel that we tested I had added in 10
additional Nova floor dies just to see
what happened in terms of the spread and
the end mixing and so you can see here
this is a way to evaluate these
additional targets and so when you're
looking at you know the blue laser
there's very little spread here and this
is showing you in this case the column
sum
and in this I had removed the Fitzy
antibody and you can see you could
actually use all of these different Nova
floor dyes together in the panel and one
of the good things about having removed
Fitzy and bb515 as compared to the
previous panel is that those were the
most similar of the dies versus the
others that I'm showing you here Nova
floor PLU 510 530 555. so this actually
then helped reduce spread but what you
can tell right away is that there's a
big issue with spread
um you know with as we've built more
dies using uh the red laser excitation
and while I won't go into that I'll just
show you very quickly you can see that
we added a number of red excited dies
and in general I would not recommend
using APC Alexa floor 647 and Nova red
660 because they are very similar in
that context so I'll go back
and so this is a way to iteratively
really evaluate your panel
so in terms of thinking of additional
resources for panel design Therma Fisher
has a number of options so you know we
have the first panel on us program so
that's something where you can reach out
to get help with designing your panel so
that's there there are also a lot of
really good tools online so you know
looking at either for conventional or
spectral cytometry the panels on design
tools so you can actually see you know
where are these Spectra and if you
already had a certain number of
antibodies in your panel it's able to
deal with that so you could say I
already have say these 10 antibodies and
now I want to add these other five in
there and it will provide
recommendations and then you still want
to of course evaluate that using your
own judgment is it matching the
brightness that you need
um you know is it you know an unusual
floor where you need to really leave
space because it's going to be you know
restricted in some way are you having to
do a conjugation things like that but a
lot of research Source online so I would
encourage everyone to check that out
and so you know in summary when you
think about you know really your
spectral panel building goals and
validation it's a really good idea to
leave space for fluorophores and the
panel to allow for easier incorporation
of the rear antigens as I mentioned so
things like Fitzy PE APC are typically
often available in you know if you have
something that's new and restricted that
might be available only in those colors
to really consider immune population
biology and resolution when building a
broad versus deep immune panel so to
step back about what that means for
instance if you're building something
and you have an incredibly you know rare
population and need a certain amount of
brightness you really might need to take
out a certain number of floors to get as
good of a detection as you want because
you will start to lose some of your
resolution as you build to more colors
so that's important to really think
about
um also thinking about matching that
brightness if it's really a dim
population and then you know thinking
about in a deep panel you're going to
really be dealing a lot more with dye
performance than a broad panel where you
could position you know for instance
antibodies that would only be expressed
on B cells or T cells or antigen
presenting cells for instance to avoid
those more problematic dye combinations
um that uh problematic dye combinations
are not always identified with just the
similarity index and the complexity
score so as I pointed out you know the
similarity index will identify something
pairwise that's happening and the
complexity score will tell you overall
you know how does this overall panel
compare to something else but um of a
similar size but it doesn't necessarily
capture you know for instance if you do
have this spectral bunching and so just
being aware to kind of think about you
know have I put three very similar dies
in a similar space in the panel and
maybe I want to avoid that
um
to you know last you know as you after
you've you know built your panel
titrated you know really thought about
the populations you need to resolve to
identify and build around problematic
perpetrator dies and reduce spectral
victims using the spectral spread Matrix
so really looking at that Row in column
sum
um and it's a relative score so the idea
is you know you could do this just as
well on an attune versus an aurora in
terms of you know a conventional or uh
spectral panel but you really need to
sort of be thinking about where are the
places where you know unfortunately
especially in a spectral panel this
might not be the best way that you've
built that
and in the end it's not about how many
colors you have in your panel but the
resolution of the underlying biology
that matters and so that's really
important to keep in mind you know you
could build 40 colors but if you don't
have resolution the populations that you
need then it doesn't matter because
that's going to affect your ability to
publish and get you know an
understanding of the data that you
really need so keeping that in mind as
you build to that and so with that I
want to thank everyone for their
attention and I'll be happy to take any
questions
thank you setting for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question today
what is the size of the fighting
yeah so the fight time is about 20
nanometers if you measure across the
cruciform structure it's about 150
kilodons so just to give you some kind
of you know measure PE is often I think
in the 220 range so similar about
similar in size to that
thank you question two is cell blocks in
FC block yeah really good question I
think there's a lot still to be
understood about
um you know different blocking reagents
so FC block cell blocks is not an FC
block cell blocks is required with all
Nova Flores and what it does is prevent
prevent bad interactions between dyes
and cells and so you know this would
give you additional background I would
recommend adding that into your antibody
mixture because it will give you you
know the best blocking
um as well as you can add you know
either the brilliant or the super bright
buffer so those are actually blocking
die die interactions for the polymer
guys and so you can actually use FC
block a brilliant or super bright buffer
block and the cell blocks all together
to prevent any um you know basically
non-specific binding that you may run
into but they do work in three different
ways
very good thank you next question can I
get a one-to-one labeling using a
conjugation kit
so yeah really good question I didn't go
into that so much today
um but you know what we have is
um the the conjugation kits work by
attaching an oligo to the antibody and
then uh the and basically that oligo
antibody can be annealed to the Nova
floor of interest and so that is a
one-to-one ratio however with uh the
conjugation kits the difference is that
we are you know purifying when we sell
our antibodies and get that one-to-one
labeling we are actually purifying out
excess dye and so with the conjugation
kits you might be adding more dye into
that mixture so you don't fully get that
one-to-one limit versus say getting that
purified
okay well that brings us to our next
question are Nova floors tandem dies
yeah really good question and you know
slightly complicated answer so they are
tandem dies in that they you know use
basically fret
um so a donor and acceptor molecule to
help trans transfer you know that signal
and so we typically think about tandem
dies as having that the difference
however tandem dies are also is a term
used to indicate the fact that you know
something like PE size seven you can't
really control chemically how much size
7 you have and so in flow cytometry
tandem dyes have been used with the idea
that okay you know if you have more size
sevens on this particular PE versus
another conjugate you know you would
really need that specific lot because it
would affect the signature you have so
the difference here we try to think
about Nova floors as being an entirely
different category of of dies and the
reason for that is that
um you know the signature is the same
and that's because we're positioned
positioning the donor and the
acceptorate precise positions and so
it's going to be the same you know every
time in terms of those positions of the
die
thank you
next question we have
just came through can Nola floors be
used for applications outside of flow
yeah so we're definitely working on that
um and I think
um I would say there's there's more to
come
um we're certainly looking at things
like microscopy
um so I'd say keep watching the space
for that
okay and does buffer composition impact
NF fluorescence
um so when you think about
um the Nova Flora fluorescence there's
no real
um quenching per se
um so we've you know looked at fixing
this with different dyes
um or sorry look at looked at different
Nova floors and then different fixation
procedures so none of the buffers really
seem to affect the Nova fluoroso for
instance you might be thinking about for
instance super bright and Brilliant eyes
where they have that interaction and
sometimes there are issues with using
that blocking solution that affect that
there's really no issue for that with
the Nova floors
um there is some uh I think when you fix
with para formaldehyde there are
differences in a number of in some
floors in terms of that staining index
but we really don't notice anything
that's specific to Nova floors that's
just true for a number of dyes
yeah it looks like we're nearing the end
here we have time for just one more
question this final question is
can cell blocks be used with dyes other
than Nova floors yes and it will
actually help
um especially
um with tandem dies and non-specific
binding so for instance monocytes will
tend to sometimes take up
um tandem dies a little bit and so
you'll see more background and so it's
very it performs very similarly to say A
True True stained monocyte blocking
buffer in that it will prevent some of
those
um you know non-specific binding to the
tandem die so it will help overall with
other other
floors in your panel
terrific well thank you set in uh before
we wrap up do you have any final
comments for our audience today
um no I just want to thank every
thank you friends you know please let me
or the team know if there's any
additional questions we're certainly
happy to follow up with you on
that terrific well thanks again seven
for your time today and your
presentation we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
thanks